le procès pour corruption de jacob zuma
a repris ce matin en afrique du sud
après plusieurs jours d'émeutes
il se déroule sous haute sécurité
l'incarcération de l'ancien président
entraîné la semaine dernière à des
scènes de violence et de pillage sans
précédent elles ont fait près de 200
morts des attaques coordonnées et
planifiée selon l'actuel chef de l'état
à cyril ramaphosa vois ça va être
quelque peu la cia aux journalistes pour
irriter internationale le procès de
l'ancien président sud africain jacob
zuma reprend aujourd'hui lundi ici dans
sa province natale le kwazulu natal en
afrique du sud
certains craignent la reprise des
pillages et violences des troubles de la
semaine dernière des scènes que
l'afrique du sud n'avait plus connu
depuis des décennies jacob zuma est sous
le coup de sept chefs d'accusation pour
fraude corruption et raquettes
il clame son innocence de même que ses
soutiens mais les tribunaux l'ont
déclarée coupable en fin de mois dernier
outrage à la cour et faire incarcérer ce
qui a déclenché la récente vague de
violences dont nous avons été témoins
c'est pourquoi certains redoutent de
nouveaux troubles les violences ont
causé la mort de plus de 200 personnes
et non seulement ici mais dans tout le
pays le président cyril ramaphosa a
déclaré qu'il s'agissait d'une attaque
coordonnée bien organisée contre le
gouvernement
la situation est certainement semer la
discorde au sein du parti du congrès
national africain personnes ont suggéré
qu'il y aurait une troisième force en
jeu pour d'autres il s'agit d'une
tentative de coup d'état
la plupart des personnes avec lesquelles
je me suis entretenu disent que les
violences sont loin d'être terminée et
nous nous attendons aujourd'hui adoptant
ces nouveaux heurts
beaucoup sont d'accord pour dire qu'il
s'agit de criminels et de jantes renom
vient
profitant de l'occasion pour piller des
commerces et récupérer autant de
marchandises gratuite que poutine
l'audience risque de raviver des
tensions c'est pourquoi la police
l'armée et les forces de sécurité
communautaire sont prêtes à l'action au
cours des derniers jours j'ai parcouru
l'afrique du sud à d'urban dans le
kwazulu natal
les gens font la queue pendant des
heures devant les commerces sont restés
ouverts pour acheter des denrées de base
calculée du pain de nombreuses boutiques
ont été pillées les autres ont fermé
afin de se protéger
il ya également une pénurie d'argent
liquide et jay que devant les
distributeurs la nuit parfois même le
jour on peut voir des membres de la
communauté armées patrouillant les rues
les hommes notamment les carrefours et
des quartiers marchands afin d'empêcher
les pilleurs d'attendre ses hôtes
windows
rs oui en sommes dans l'expectative de
violences qui pourraient s'exacerber
dans le courant de la journée et je vous
tiendrai informé des événements procès
anti l'opep